[Applause]
[Music]
among all the health threats that exist
in the world today right now it's a
virus that stands head and shoulders
above all others there is virtually no
headline or program that doesn't address
the news it's the news events of the
year and the truth is that to this day
it's not about the number of people
infected or the apparent lafalot e that
worries us sits above all else the
newness of the threat and the fact that
we still do not know exactly what we're
facing that makes it quite so terrifying
there are no vaccines and beyond the
treatment of symptoms there isn't a
specific cure I'm sure you don't need
any more clues at this point sir no
we're talking about do you
yes exactly we're talking about who Hans
famous coronavirus the kovat 19 disease
that is spreading around the world and
has not yet reached its peak of
infection at the time of producing this
video the virus has reached 37 countries
more than 90,000 people have been
infected and of them more than 3,200
have succumbed to the disease as you're
probably aware this new strain of
coronavirus the seventh one to be
identified is believed to have
originated in a food market in the
Chinese city of Wuhan we're live animals
including wild animals of salt as you
can imagine such an epidemic and have a
great impacts on all levels and look I'm
not just talking about health but also
the knock-on effects in politics and of
course the consequences for the economy
China's coronavirus has revived global
economic fears the New York Times
Alibaba warns virus having broad impact
on Chinese economy
factories facing severe labor shortages
in China US business group says forbes
stocks tumble as haven assets rally on
coronavirus spheres investors have
rushed out of equities and into havens
such as gold and US government bonds
following a surge in coronavirus cases
in Italy South Korea and Iran over the
weekend that intensified concerns over
the global impact of the virus
of course the epicenter of the full
brunt of this terrible story is still
being felt in China especially in Hebei
province which is where Wuhan is located
the city where the outbreak allegedly
started China has suffered intensely
from the threat of the coronavirus city
streets are now virtually empty many
factories malls and shops of all kinds
have closed their doors people are
afraid to use public transport and some
places like who their province are still
paralyzed locked down in quarantine
people can't leave their houses and even
car journeys have been banned Britain
permits are needed for everything you
can no longer go to the pharmacy or to
do your grocery shopping now everything
has to be ordered online
in an upcoming video Aaron is your
politic we're gonna discuss in detail
what the long-term economic consequences
of such a threat might be so you know if
you haven't done so already make sure
you're subscribed keep up to date with
what's going on
however in this video we're talking
about Cathay Pacific Hong Kong's
flagship airline that's having a really
hard time right now
so you might be wondering well why on
earth are we going to talk about an
airline well because this company Cathay
Pacific is a good example of how
everything related to economics can
suffer with the outbreak of the corona
virus and that not even this major
health threat has been enough to stop
the expansionism of the Chinese
government
but let's start at the beginning while
companies around the world have begun to
suffer due to a scarcity and components
from Chinese suppliers due to factory
closures and a lack of workers Cathay
Pacific is missing passengers okay in
Hong Kong cases still Hoffer around 100
but fear is in the air and this epidemic
couldn't have come at a worse time for
the airline anti-government protests
that have been burning in the streets of
Hong Kong for months census of which we
have already discussed here on visual
politic of course two rivals visitors
and tourists to the city to fall faster
than the value of the Argentinean peso
in 2019 nine million fewer visitors
arrived in Hong Kong compared to the
previous yet and now with the
coronavirus all signs indicate the 2020
could be even worse during January 2020
visitors to Hong Kong dropped 53 percent
compared to that same month in the
previous year and in January 2020 the
specter of the corona virus was
relatively smaller that makes the
forecasts for the coming months pretty
bleak so what kind of companies do you
think suffer the most in circumstances
like this well yes obviously it's hotels
and our lines those kinds of businesses
feel the pinch as people stay home the
political crisis in Hong Kong was a
major blow to Cathay Pacific now the
impact of the corona virus could be the
last straw now exactly how great is the
full house how is the appearance of the
corona virus affecting this airline and
what steps are they taking what is the
future of a company that has already
been suffering an unprecedented crisis
for almost a year
over the past few years Cathay Pacific's
story has been filled with misfortune
political blackmail threats and
political layoffs listen to this
[Music]
Kathie's annus horribilis before we
start talking about Cathay Pacific's
problems I think it's best to get a
deeper understanding of the company
Cathay Pacific is a flagship company
Hong Kong's most important company we're
not exactly talking about a small
airline but one of the largest air
groups across the Asian continent for
you to get an idea the size of its fleet
today is 152 aircrafts and all of them a
wide-body craft it's not only that
besides the main airline brands this
company also operates another subsidiary
Cafe Dragon with a fleet of 48 more
aircrafts and a cargo subsidiary our
Hong Kong with 11 aircraft that is we're
talking about an air group with more
than 200 operational aircraft and routes
to 130 destinations across the globe
[Music]
however 2019 turned out to be a horrible
year and as we have mentioned 2020 could
be even worse during the first month of
2020 passenger arrivals at Hong Kong
Airport ooh decreased by 40 percent
year-on-year
this is hence that both the number of
passengers and the volume of cargo
carried by this airline has been in
freefall in recent months you see in
aviation occupancy data is usually
measured by the passenger load
coefficient which calculates the
relationship between seats per kilometer
and offered by an airline and seats that
were occupied
[Music]
as you can see the second half of 2019
was horrible for Cathay compared to 2018
and it's a similar story with the cargo
subsidiary
in other words this is a clear
illustration of the economic damage that
has resulted from the difficult
political situation that Hong Kong is
going through at present it also
explains news stories like this one Hong
Kong suffers first annual recession in a
decade Hong Kong's economy contracted by
1.2 percent in 2019 global trade
turbulence in months of anti-government
protests pushed the city into its first
annual recession since the depths of the
global financial crisis in 2009 Wall
Street Journal and now there's also the
coronavirus to contend with Kathy
Pacific issues profit warning after
Coronas virus hits service The Guardian
perhaps all of this explains why Kathy's
shares have reached their lowest point
in more than 10 years however this is
not the only threats facing the airline
nor the population of Hong Kong because
the truth is that we may be witnessing
what is perhaps the last move in a game
that could put an end to Hong Kong as we
know it check this out
is the future in China's hands when a
company is struggling apart from the
shareholders the first ones to notice
the consequence are usually the
employees following the coronavirus
epidemic cafe has been forced to suspend
90 percent of flights to mainland China
and 30 percent of its flights globally
with such severe cuts to their services
the company has asked 27,000 employees
to take 3 weeks of unpaid leave to
reduce fixed costs and try to cope with
the difficult situation that it's faced
with however this is not the only
problem facing this airline remember how
we were talking about the protests in
Hong Kong
well the drop in visitor numbers was by
no means the only negative impacts from
that event the Cathay Pacific faced
[Music]
a familiar with consequences of angering
the Chinese regime well let's just say
the cafe completed an accelerated
masters degree in that matter you see
after the protests broke out several
workers who participated in them were
unlucky enough to be identified by the
Chinese authorities
and you know what Beijing did well they
said good job controlling your employees
they keep participating in the protest
soon you're going to realize the error
of your ways
soon you won't have a single permit to
fly in China you know trademark
authoritarian moves the pressure from
the Chinese government that said that
the airline had not done enough to
control the political activities of its
workers ended up in the resignation of
the former CEO Rupert Hogg and the
president of Cathay himself Jang slow
saw following these two resignations the
airline launched a heavy-handed policy
against all those employees who
participated in the protests and even
those who showed support for the cause
through social media campaigns at least
two dozen workers were instantly
dismissed yes China is forcing a company
to curb the political participation of
its employees it's crazy but that's just
how she drinking's government rolls but
this shady story doesn't end here here
on visual politic we've already told you
how the Republic of China is trying by
all means possible to consolidate its
power in Hong Kong well now it seems the
Chinese government has found a new way
to attack
and they explained Cathay Pacific's
problems sewing from the Hong Kong
protests and exacerbated by the corona
virus might just be the golden
opportunity for China once and for all
take control of Hong Kong's main
transportation provider and it's nothing
if not determined for more than a decade
China's quintessential state airline Air
China has owned 30% of Cathay Pacific's
shares it's the second largest
shareholder behind Hong Kong groups hua
Pacific which controls 45% of the shares
so the truth is that if the Hong Kong
Airlines bad run continues China could
be in an optimal position to inject
capital and take control of the company
in this way its control over the lives
of Hong Kong is and the future of this
city it would be even greater yes this
shows us that she doing things
government knows how to take advantage
of all situations even one as terrible
as that fostered by coronavirus in any
case when it comes to Hong Kong it seems
that in Beijing they have a clear idea
the worse it gets down there the better
it will be for China Cathay Pacific is
nothing more than a microcosm of
everything that is happening in Hong
Kong socially burning city that every
day seems closer to being devoured by
the Chinese Giants so I really hope you
enjoyed this video please do hit that
like button if you did and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos please
do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode but we're not
mine also this channel is possible
because a patreon ends our patrons on
that platform please consider joining
them in as always thank you for watching
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and here's some more
of my lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider at
WWE consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]
you